hello everyone and welcome to a
wonderful game that was played in 1918
in new york by none other than former
world champion jose raul capoblanca it
comes as a suggestion from user uh kappa
kappa forever
and uh he said that it's it's a
wonderful game that shows uh how you
cannot repeat chess moves forever and we
often discuss this but i don't think
we've ever shown a game uh that uh
well shows you shows you why this is so
now to those of you who who play chess
on a regular basis uh this uh goes
without saying but for those of you who
are new to chess it might be odd why
wouldn't just why wouldn't black just
play whatever white plays only from
black's perspective uh because there's
this thing in chess called a check and
when you are in check you cannot do
whatever you want you have to deal with
check and only after you have dealt with
check you are allowed to continue doing
whatever you want to do so here
capablanca really shows in this uh
brilliancy miniature how uh it's
impossible to keep it even even for uh a
little while so the game is super short
you guys will we love it uh and
capablanca punishes the symmetry with
absolute surgical precision as usual so
let's check it out uh capablanca has the
white pieces and he opens with e4 now
our mr hoodie guy replies with e5 uh
that's why i i am wearing a hoodie this
video hope you guys are as well knight
to f3 knight to c6 knight to c3 and
knight to f6 now okay now you might say
okay but this wasn't really symmetrical
because there was knight f3 knight to c6
knight to c3 and only then knight to f6
uh while this is true
as of this moment on as of move three it
is now most uh definitely a symmetrical
game so bishop to c4 we have bishop to
c5 going into the
joko piano the four knights variation of
the joko piano capoblanca castles our
mystery person castles and uh capoblanca
prepares to develop the bishop
and mr hoody guy does the same he plays
d6 wants to play bishop to g4 bishop to
g5 with bishop to g4 and now knight to
d5 oh this of course makes sense the
knight is pinned so we want to attack it
we want to mess up black spawn structure
in front of the king and this is exactly
what black does knight to d4 so the idea
is the same the knight is pinned we want
to capture on f3 so here uh you might
try a couple of different ideas but the
move capablanca plays is the absolute
strongest one and that is queen to d2
the queen will be very useful along this
diagonal as you know that once this uh
anything that captures on f6 uh black
will have to capture with the g pawn if
he doesn't want to give up the queen and
then the queen gets access to the h6
square
and black should really say all right uh
enough with this symmetry nonsense i'm
just going to trade here for example
captures captures bishop captures an f3
and white will play something like h3
make room for his king on h2 prepare
rook to g1 and continue the attack uh
and even though for the moment it's uh
the white king that is filling the uh
the breeze it is definitely white who is
attacking here uh but black continues
with the symmetry we have queen to d7 he
says if it's good enough for capablanca
it's good enough for me
uh and now comes bishop captures an f6
knight captures on f6 is even more
forcing as it comes with check right
away uh but i think couple blanca wanted
to have a little a little bit of fun and
he allowed black to keep the symmetry
going for one more move so here we have
bishop captures on f6 bishop captures on
f3 now the position is symmetrical for
for 10 moves now however on move 11 it
is no longer possible to keep the
symmetry knight the e7 with check and
now as black is in check black does not
have the option of going knight to e2
with check first you have to deal with
this and uh of course uh you have to
move the king or or you capture here and
then you've just given up your queen so
obviously we're not going to do that so
king the h8 was played and now uh well
feel free to pause the video and try to
find a forced checkmate uh for
capoblanca while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this very
very forcing line and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is of
course bishop captures on g7 with check
uh if you're if you thought maybe the
queen to g5 this is also just winning
then just rook to g8 this is a perfectly
uh reasonable move even though it seems
like bla white can capture this rook we
just bring the other rook here and now
the g7 point is defended and it's
actually black who's going to win this
game so you have to be very careful not
to do that but uh
after this bishop to g7 move now there
is nothing for black to do here the
bishop must be captured the g8 square is
covered by the knight so king captures
now comes queen to g5 with check and now
you see how the queen being on d2
makes all of this possible so now queen
to g5 with czech king the h8 and of
course queen to f6 this is now checkmate
as like we said the knight covers the g8
square so a very very nice game by none
other than josero capoblanca himself on
how symmetry in chess is
is not possible or not not even viable
for a very long time you can repeat a
few moves and pretty much any opening
has a symmetrical variation so you can
maybe push it to around move six maybe
seven but as you can see once it reaches
move 10 the position just collapses and
um that's that's just it okay these are
open games this was a an italian game
maybe in some super close structures
maybe it's possible to keep the symmetry
going a little bit longer but if you're
a beginner chances are you are playing
open games and you should always be
be careful of this nasty thing called
check
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it thank you for suggesting such
a such a wild wild capablanca game i
would like to thank david kimura john
give john gilfoyle dominic novieli adam
rosenberg and francis ayer for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions such as this one
and whatever else happens in the chess
world so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day